last october by the way as those
caravans were approaching the US border
on this show
I warned of something that was being
lost in the greater debate watch this is
a national security issue an economic
issue cost taxpayers billions of dollars
to take all these people in public
schools health care all of it we know
it's a health issue too because we don't
know what people have coming in here we
have diseases in this country we haven't
had for decades
well the backlash I received was Swift
I was immediately vilified for saying
such a thing how dare it Business
Insider called it a conspiracy theory in
the Washington Post said it was
dehumanizing well when you know it today
reuters reported or yesterday excuse me
that outbreaks of infectious diseases
among migrants including cases of the
mumps measles etc have forced over 2,000
of them into quarantine at various
detention centers across the country
so my question will those critics now go
after Reuters it's at all dehumanizing
joining me now to discuss this way
beyond mumps is mark Segal dr. Segal I
was flayed for warning about this but
this is a real health risk to American
citizens especially American
schoolchildren is it not absolutely
right Laura
you know the Immigration and Customs
Enforcement has has their hands full
fifty thousand in detention centers and
as you just pointed out over two
thousand now in quarantine mumps travels
through the air mumps you may not have
symptoms in you're spreading it measles
as well also chickenpox also there's
cases of tuberculosis being found you
know the biggest issue is that the
Centers for Disease Control will screen
legal immigrants you're not allowed into
this country legally unless they check
your measles mumps rubella titer
chickenpox
you have to prove that you've received
the vaccine and that it's working well
CDC told me tonight that they're playing
catch-up now ice is going to have to
call them in to the quarantine people
and to revaccinated to see if their
immune status is there
you're absolutely right calling this a
public health emergency that's part of
the problem here it's a big part of the
problem and it ties in with national
security multiple diseases are coming in
with the migrants
well dr. Siegel also when someone comes
in and you say well have you been
vaccinated I mean how are you can ever
check that I mean you can't really
there's no there's no like legitimate
way to check I call Condor as well has X
Y or Z gotten you know the various
tetanus shot I mean you can't you can't
really check that right we have enough
problems I think and with people in the
country not being vaccinated that big
controversy but now this I mean we are
over whelmed and they're gonna vilify
Alex a czar at HHS the Secretary of HHS
what is he supposed to do the Democrats
don't want to deal with this issue he's
left to pick up the pieces
by the way Laura you not only can't
check it you can't take someone's word
for it cuz of course to get it say yes
ma'am yes sir but also it wears off this
vaccine wears off especially with mumps
and you know mumps can cause infertility
it can cause brain swelling so these are
not just minor childhood diseases we're
talking about we're seeing a measles
resurgence mainly across the border and
then people that don't get vaccinated
like you said people that refuse to get
back say it spreads like wildfire to the
unvaccinated population this is a threat
a public health threat also
mosquito-borne diseases there's 400,000
cases of malaria coming in tuberculosis
so I don't know why I don't know why the
list doesn't want to talk about it it's
actually it's an actual issue but again
back to the point I made in the angle
they do not want to have a debate on
these issues because they can't debate
it all they can say is you're racist
you're xenophobic you're a dehumanizing
you're cruel you're me that's all they
have because you get down to the facts
they are putting Americans at risk and
Trump and his policies are actually
geared dr. Siegel towards keeping our
people safe that's his first and most
solemn obligation to keep the American
people safe and he's trying to do that
he's not perfect none of us are willing
to do that more the CDC who's really
nonpartisan calls this playing catch up
there in the country then we got to
figure out what diseases they may carry
that says it all
that says it all dr. Siegel thank you so
much